so this was this was pretty inspiring
Caroline Rothstein as a feminist on
Twitter and apparently she described
herself as an internationally touring
writer poet performer and educator and I
guess this happened on one of her
international tours where she was
performing and educating and she tweeted
this she said saying no thank you I got
it too the middle-aged white man on the
on the airplane who offered and began to
take my suitcase out of the overhead
compartment for me was a quickly
calculated act of resistance so she was
resisting resisting resistance by by
declining a polite gesture from a man
now this obviously I mean goes without
saying this is brave this is courageous
this is stunning and beautiful honestly
I'm always so grateful to feminists for
this kind of stuff because what
feminists can do and they have an
incredible knack for this is they could
sort of dig under what appears to be a
very routine act of kindness or courtesy
just a normal interaction between people
they can dig under that and they can
discover underneath all of that
persecution there they're very good at
at their like persecution treasure
hunters where you know they don't even
need a they don't need an X on the map
they don't need metal detector they'll
find it you know you bury persecution
under a stack of needles they'll find it
like someone's being nice right and you
and I as idiots we think oh that
person's being nice but what feminists
do then this is really all they do this
is our whole mission in life this is
their whole thing they come in and they
say no that wasn't nice that was
actually bad let me explain why which is
good for me even as a man because
feminists say that when a man tries to
help a woman with her bags or hold a
door open or whatever he's really
promoting the patriarchy and he's being
patronizing but the thing is as a man
there are plenty of times when men have
held the door open for me or if I'm on a
plane and you know my bag is a few rows
up and I can't reach it if there's a guy
standing there there's plenty of times
we'll just grab the bag and hand it to
me right just in Norton here you go
but and I always thought okay that's
just normal courtesy really normal thing
to do what I'm learning is that that's
really an act of
dominance so he's saying what he's
saying audibly is here let me Greta for
you but what he's really saying is back
up you puny weakling with your twig arms
let a real man handle this
and then he grabs it there you go
I see I never I I have to remember to be
offended in the future by that because I
never saw it that way so I'm so glad
that feminists could enlighten me
alright now before we before we move on
entirely from the mass shootings over
the weekend I said yesterday that the
country will probably have forgotten
about it by Thursday it looks like maybe
we need to move that timeline up to
Wednesday or today I don't know but
before we have forgotten which we always
do I think there's more to be said on
the subject one main point in particular
that somehow isn't discussed that often
it's actually pretty amazing when you
think about it that we don't talk more
much much more about this point that I'm
gonna raise and I'm not the first person
raised it of course but it's it it
should be front and center in our minds
it should be maybe the main thing we
talk about in relation to these
shootings and that point is this that
nearly every single mass shooter in the
history of the country and nearly all of
the mass shooters who comprise the
recent epidemic the spike in mass
shootings over the past decade or so
almost all of them with very very very
rare exception are men young men mostly
again with rare exception the Las Vegas
shooter was was older it was an older
he's a man but he was older almost all
of them are young men and in fact for
this you could expand the definition of
mass shooter to include you know drug
violence gang violence all the stuff
that happens in the city which of course
is much more common than this other kind
of mass shooting which which itself is
far more common than it should be but he
expanded include that it's still it's
all young men almost all young men I
mean for the sake of simplicity and for
argument I'm just going to say all men
because that's
basically what it is how is it that we
aren't focusing intently on that fact
how is it that we're talking about guns
and all this other stuff when nearly
every mass shooter fits so neatly into
the same demographic shouldn't we be
discussing that I mean imagine for a
moment that the next say for mass
shooters were women all between the ages
of 18 and 22 just imagine that for a
second now you can't imagine it because
it would never happen but just imagine
that the next format mass shooters are
women well after four probably after two
of them maybe even after one we would be
it would be a crisis we would be asking
you know we'd be saying what's going on
with our girls how is this happening
with our girls huh what are we doing
that's resulting in girls acting this
way it would be a huge topic of
conversation be the only thing we talked
about really in relation to the mass
shooting is the fact that these are
girls and what's going on with that but
when you have hundreds and hundreds of
thousands again if you count the mass
shootings in the city which for this in
this case you should thousands of boys
doing this and all we say is well okay
that's alright I think that's wrong and
I think we need to talk about I want to
talk about the gender factor of this and
we will do that but first before we get
to that a quick word from our friends at
expressvpn you know admit it you think
that cybercrime is something that
happens to other people I know that I
can lapse into thinking of it this way
as well you may you may think that no
one wants your data right there they're
going after other people you don't have
to worry about it as much that hackers
can't grab your password or your credit
card details but of course you'd be
wrong about that stealing data from
unsuspecting people on public Wi-Fi is
one of the simplest and cheapest ways
for hackers to make money and if you use
public Wi-Fi I use it all the time
whatever you're doing if you don't have
protection whatever you're doing there
someone who has just a rudimentary
understanding of how to hack into other
people they can access it when you leave
your internet connection unencrypted you
might as well be writing your passwords
and credit card numbers on a huge
billboard for the rest of the world to
see because again if someone just has a
little bit of knowledge on how to
into into you know if you have a base a
sort of junior level hacker would be
able to access it and that's why I
decided finally to take action to
protect myself from cyber criminals I
use Express VPN expressvpn secures and
and makes anonymous your internet
browsing by encrypting your data and
hiding your public IP address expressvpn
has easy-to-use apps that run seamlessly
in the background of your computer phone
and tablet it really I mean it's it's
reckless honestly to not have this
product you need you need something like
this to protect yourself turning on
expressvpn protection only takes one
click it's so easy to do you're
protecting yourself until it's you know
too late and they've hacked it and
they've taken your information using
expressvpn I can safely surf on public
Wi-Fi without being snooped on having my
personal data stolen protect your online
activity today and find out how you can
get three months for you to Express VPN
dot-com slash Walsh
that's exp ress VPN dot-com slash Walsh
for three months free with a young
one-year package visit expressvpn
dot-com slash Walsh to learn more ok so
almost every mass shooter is a young man
why is that what's going on I think
that's a question that we should be
asking well won't shock you to learn
that the first thing I'm going to point
to in explaining why it's always young
men doing this is the thing that I
mentioned yesterday fatherlessness
broken homes a disproportionate number
of these boys especially in the
inner-city and especially among school
shooters specifically don't have dads in
the home and and even many that do have
dads in the home the dad is emotionally
or psychologically absent or worse or
actively abusive so the dad factor here
is unmistakable but then the question
arises ok if you you know there are just
as many girls who stands the reason
they're just as many girls who have
living in fatherless homes as boys why
does it have this
special impact on boys rather than girls
why is that why are boys more likely to
go down this violent path if their dad
for whatever reason fails to be present
fails to be active and engaged it's not
enough to just point to fatherlessness
and say well there's the problem I think
the why really matters and we need to
talk about the why as far as the why
there are many probably countless ways
that a boy
especially is affected by not having his
dad around but let me point to three of
the most obvious ones first boys as I'm
sure you've noticed have a ton of
aggression they they have a ton of
physical energy and so they need safe
and healthy outlets for that aggression
and for that that that energy they need
it okay need it's an actual need it's
not like it would be best if they had it
Oh what gee wouldn't it be nice no it's
an actual real physical need they have
if the dad's not in the picture of
course there are things that a mother
can do to compensate it's not like you
know it's it's hopeless and there's
nothing you can do now and in fact
especially in in the cities this is
where sports become so important you
know probably millions of boys have been
saved from a life of you know of drug
dealing and gang banging by getting
involved in in football or basketball
not just as an outlet for their
aggression although it is that also but
then in the bargain they also get access
to a football coach who's gonna be a
male role model and authoritative
no-nonsense disciplined male role model
which is indispensable but there's still
no replacing the advantage of having
that male role model actually in the
home and there are things that a father
can do when it comes to giving their
their son and outlet for energy and
aggression that a mother can't do or
probably won't do or that a son isn't
going to look to the mother to do right
so for instance I wrestle with my boys
all the time it was one of the main
things that I think a father needs to do
with his young boys is just kind of
horse around with them you know
roughhousing and things well
I'm able to do less of it now after the
Achilles injury so I've had to take a
break from it although sometimes my sons
will still come in and just jump on it
even when I even when I was laid up on
the couch and I was in a cast like a day
after surgery my son ran up and just and
basically just piledrive me because you
know that's that's how you see there's
there's even wrote a whole book on it
hop on pop I mean it's an entire book
about you know physically abusing your
father so but I think that this is this
is an all seriousness something that
that fathers should need to be doing
with their sons to give them that outlet
for aggression my oldest son
well Alec as I just mentioned but
especially when I'm when I'm able to
walk heel just out of nowhere sometimes
just come leaping from the couch or
similar onto my back like a spider
monkey and they just start punching me
in the shoulder now a boy isn't gonna do
that with his mom and probably should
that's what fathers are for now the
trouble comes in and this could happen
even with a father around like I said
just because a father is there doesn't
mean that he's actually there but the
trouble comes in when that energy and
aggression is stifled and unfortunately
these days there are many ways we have
gotten we have innovated many ways to
stifle that masculine energy that boys
have well for one thing the
pharmaceutical industry is you know they
make billions doing this so you can
always drug them you can shove chemicals
into their bodies into their mouths
chemically lobotomize them sedate them
essentially so that they're less of a
handful and that's in that book I'm not
saying that every single boy who's on
some kind of psychotropic drug is there
may be cases where it's necessary or the
right thing to do I can't I'm not gonna
rule that out I couldn't rule it out
but I think in so many cases in so many
cases this stuff is used just as
sedation
because the energy is it's a hassle to
deal with especially in school but even
at the home and so parents say look I
just I don't feel I can't deal with this
I don't feel like dealing with it
the other form of sedation more common
is TV and video games and phones the
internet the problem is that you know
boys are so rambunctious so energetic
and sedating them with TV and video
games is so easy and so on the surface
seemingly harmless that many parents
resort to this method way more often
than they should I mean we all as
parents look we've all we've all had
days at least where we rely on the TV
way more than we should I've had days
like that where you just have days or
like I just don't feel like dealing with
it just just watch TV and every once in
a while you have a day like that
it's fine because I also believe as
parents you know you need to be able to
survive psychologically and sometimes
give yourself a break and you can't beat
yourself up over that but when it
becomes a way of life and this is all
your kid does and becomes dependent upon
it well now that's that's that's a real
issue because all of specially for boys
all of that energy and that aggression
that doesn't go away just because
they're sitting there with a blank face
a blank expression staring at a TV
almost drooling like like they've been
lobotomized just because they're doing
that that doesn't mean that they've
really been calmed down and that energy
has gone away the energy is bottled up
or converted into something else and
that's the thing about energy a
physicist will tell you though this is a
different kind of energy they're talking
about but they'll do this the principle
still holds energy doesn't go away it
doesn't leave it's there forever it just
it's converted into something else
well the male energy filling I'm
sounding like Marianne Williamson now
the the energy of that connects all
people next can all be suggesting
healing crystals as a solution but but
no a boy's energy also doesn't go away
it's stifled it's bottled up and
eventually it's converted into something
else into emotional aggression defiance
backtalk
or worse so that's where I think a
father comes in giving that outlet for
aggression and it and last thing I'll
say about that I keep saying aggression
aggression in and of itself is not a bad
thing
it's just what you do with it is the
question and this is the other thing
that we do in our society where we treat
aggression as in and of itself a bad
thing and if it's if it's in and of
itself a bad thing then that means that
there is something fundamentally wrong
with all of our boys because they all
have that in them and if we're saying
there's something that aggression is is
just wrong in every context what we're
saying to our boys is there's something
wrong with you and so we're gonna drug
you or we're gonna put you in front of a
TV until we until that's been drained
out of you or stifled so much that we
can't detect it anymore and boys pick up
on that also so while we're sedating
them while we are not giving them
healthy outlets for their aggression
we're also telling them there's
something wrong with you there's
something wrong with you there's
something wrong with you and it seeps in
after a while the other thing that a
father does I think for a sudden is
facilitate risk-taking and I think this
this is a an aspect that is not talked
talked about hardly at all but you know
kids want to take risks boys and girls
but again especially boys you know boys
want to especially inclined to take
physical risks and where a father can
come in this is helping to facilitate
that risk-taking to show kids their sons
how to take those physical risks in a in
a you know sort of controlled and safe
environment the other day I took I was
out with my son and I let him you know
very normal thing I let him climb a tree
climbed it all the way pretty much to
the top now that's a risk okay he's up
he's up yeah you know 20 feet in the air
if you were to fall from there he could
get very very hurt so it is definitely a
risk but I was there I saw the tree I
could see the limbs that he was on I was
kind of coaching him through how grabbed
that limb I could see that the limbs
were sturdy okay
I was also standing there if he did fall
I'd be able to catch him so it's a
control it's a risk but it's a
controlled risk and you might say well
why take any risks at all if there's
chance that he falls and you know breaks
his leg or worse why do it at all well
because this first of all I can't
imagine you know my son having a boyhood
where that doesn't involve climbing
trees I just can't imagine that it is in
fact worth the risk and also I know that
if if I'm not allowing him to take some
risks and if he doesn't feel comfortable
taking risks around me or if he's not
even gonna ask me anymore hey daddy
could I do this or that because he knows
I'm gonna say no every time to anything
that's remotely risk well then he's not
gonna stop taking risks he's just going
to take them when I'm not in view that's
what's gonna happen or he'll stop taking
risks and then it will come out later
and that's where drug abuse you know
alcohol the partying and everything I
mean got you these these teenage boys
that go out in their in their you know
parents cars and race down the street at
90 miles per hour
that is that is uncontrolled unsafe
unfelt ated risk-taking and that's the
kind of risk-taking where people die so
so that's where fathers come in and then
finally of course and this kind of sums
it up this is the underlying thing that
beyond you know healthy outlets of
aggression beyond risk-taking included
in that but also beyond it boys need
their dads to show them what men do what
a man is what the point of a man is what
men are for they need that example from
their dad I think what we've ended up
with is a situation where there are
millions of boys out there who've never
been shown how to be men don't know what
a man is for feel like their masculinity
is a disease have been drugged into into
you know non-existence almost have spent
cumulatively years of their life their
lives staring at screens have never
learned how to interact with people in a
human human base
I have never learned how to take healthy
risks have never learned how to stick up
for themselves how to defend themselves
the other things like that that dads are
for you know teaching your son how to
throw a punch that's something a dad
should be doing how to defend themselves
encouraging them you know the dad is
supposed to be the one if your kid gets
into a fight at school the dad is
supposed to be one that says ok who took
the first swing and if you find out that
oh he's swinging at you first you defend
yourself that's ok you're not in trouble
with me I mean that's what a dad's
supposed to be there for when when all
boys have is the sort of feminine
influence now not all women are like
this but a mom is more likely to say oh
and you still don't you still don't hit
back the mom is more likely to because
she's you know she's she's the feminine
influence she's more focused on the fact
that her son is hurting he's got the
black eye that's what she's focused on
where as the father you're you know
you're worried about his physical pain
but your that's not the main thing
you're focused on you want to know that
he swing first did you win you know
that's gonna be one of your questions
boy needs that also he can't just have
the feminine influence it's not healthy
alright now so I think that's that's
part of it but yeah and I have to
stipulate this I shouldn't have to
stipulate it but I'm not look you could
have a boy who grows up with there are
many boys many millions who grow up with
no father in the house they play a lot
of video games and watch a lot of TV
they're on the drugs and they don't grow
up to become mass shooters okay that's
the vast majority of boys in that
category are not going to grow to become
mass shooters of course because for that
for that extra dramatic step of becoming
a killer there's there's gonna be a lot
more needed but boys are still being put
it in a disadvantage even if they don't
end up as mass killers there they are
still going to end up taking unhealthy
risks in some form they're still going
to end up finding unhealthy outlets for
their aggression in some form they're
still going to end up confused about who
they are
and that is in some way going to come
out
okay now here's the point where I think
probably most the people listening or
watching right now you you would
probably agree with most of what I just
said here's the part where I lose a lot
of you all right
because I could never quit when I'm
ahead I want it for a few minutes
homed in on something that I mentioned
tangentially the past couple of days I
just mentioned it today and mention
yesterday and that is the video games
specifically now it's my contention that
media our obsession with media the
saturation of media has a harmful effect
on ourselves and on our children and
when we raise our kids to be obsessed
with all forms of media they spend their
lives staring at screens that has a
certain effect on them they are
influenced by that they are influenced
by what they see on the screen they are
influenced by the media they consume I
don't think that video games are an
exception to that rule I don't think
they're special okay now I also don't
think that there are the sole culprit I
don't think that they're a special case
I just don't think they're an exception
so I'm making the statement about media
in general media influences people if
you if a kid is raised on this stuff if
it's all he does that's gonna hurt him
it's gonna influence them in a bad way
that's my point
and yeah our video games part of that of
course they are and they're a part that
that should be discussed the problem is
that we've got all these boys and young
men obsessed with media obsessed with
the screen and we all agree that that's
a problem I you know you're not gonna
find very many people say yeah yeah
whatever just let them watch as much as
I want but a lot of people because they
themselves enjoy watching video games
and they take the games very seriously
and they're very defensive and
protective about it so a lot of those
people they want they do want video
games to be an exception so that we
could talk about the ill effects of
media we could talk about the influence
of TV and movies and the internet and
all that but we can't talk about the
very form of media
that many kids spend hours a day
consuming so what you have are a lot of
gamers I talked these people all the
time any time the subject comes up their
attitude appears to be sure any yeah I
agree
kids are consuming touch media I agree
it influences them but that one form of
media that many young boys pan out spend
most of their time consuming yeah that
that you'll leave alone that's a sacred
cow we don't talk about that we don't
mention that that's fine that's harmless
let's focus on all these other forms of
media even if even if the kids are using
that less we're where video games become
this untouchable thing it's it's it's
absurdly it's childish
it's unreasonable the attitude that a
lot of people have is that you with
video games you cannot criticize them at
all I'm not exaggerating that is clearly
the attitude a lot of gamers have they
they will not listen to any criticism
none it's it's again unreasonable look
yeah I don't you could say it's easy for
me to say I don't play video games
that's right I am on the internet a lot
I make my living on the Internet
I am an Internet personality I'm afraid
to say yet I criticized the internet all
the time I did an entire show on it
yesterday
where it was one of the it was one of
the main things I pointed to as a
potential culprit in in you know in in
creating an environment where you have
mass shooters yet I'm on the internet
and I it's it's my job to be on the
internet so I am you know just because I
use something and it's important to me
in many ways it's important to me it's a
my family depends on that doesn't mean
I'm going to I'm going to suggest that
it should be immune from criticism all
I'm asking is if you're a gamers that
means stop pretending just because you
like it that we that there's no
criticism that could possibly be offered
of it it's it's it's not fair and what
you're doing is you're you're shutting
down the potential to have a very
worthwhile and valuable conversation if
when you have kids spending hours of
debt a day doing anything we should look
at what that thing is and inspect
what the influences of it might be I
mean of course we should do that
president Trump yesterday pointed a
finger not the finger not all of the
fingers he pointed one little finger at
at videogames very briefly he's gotten a
ton of blowback for it even from his
fans this this is how this is what a
sacred cow video games are that
President Trump famously I mean he's the
one who said he could shoot someone on
Fifth Avenue onus and his fans would
still like him that's probably true you
know he could say whatever he wants and
his most hardcore supporters are gonna
go in line with him yesterday I saw
people who I've never ever ever seen
criticized Trump over anything all of a
sudden now they've turned on him because
of video games that's the one thing he's
not that's where they draw the line you
could say anything else you want
if you touch video games now we've got
issues so here's what Trump had to say
watch this we must recognize that the
Internet has provided a dangerous Avenue
to radicalize disturbed minds and
perform demented X we must shine light
on the dark recesses of the Internet and
stop mass murders before they start the
internet likewise is used for human
trafficking illegal drug distribution
and so many other heinous crimes the
perils of the internet and social media
cannot be ignored and they will not be
ignored we must stop the glorification
of violence in our society this includes
the gruesome and grisly video games that
are now commonplace it is too easy today
for troubled youth to surround
themselves with a culture that
celebrates violence we must stop or
substantially reduce this and it has to
begin immediately okay what's his point
well just that kids are influenced by
what they see it they spend hours a day
playing violent video games they'll
probably be influenced by that will it
cause them to commit a shooting no will
it make them no will it hijack their
brains and turn them into you know
hypnotize them with our eyes become
little squiggly circles and you know
like in the cartoons that no it's no one
is suggesting that it's just an
influence one influence of many but an
important one to look at
gamers what gamers like to do is they
like to strawman this argument they say
things like hey I played Super Mario
World when I was when I was a kid you
know I didn't make me eat shrooms and
jump into drainage pipes okay obviously
hey come on don't don't waste my time
and a please I mean if you're watching
this right now you're listening don't
please don't waste my time with that
kind of stuff in the comments whether
nobody is saying that that's not you you
know that nobody is saying it you know
that's a straw man of course no one is
arguing that there is that direct of a
correlation between playing video games
and and you know committing violence or
reckless acts it's it's not a one-to-one
connection but let me ask you if your
kid was watching pepper the pig and
Peppa all the sudden pulled out a bomb
okay and started ripping bong hits
would you how would you feel about that
would would you like it would you be
fine with it would you say it's a Todd
mattress what does she got what just
because she sees that she's gonna run
out and find a drug dealer and get some
weed no of course that's not what's
gonna happen but you probably wouldn't
be a fan of pep of the pig doing ripping
bong hits or a Mickey Mouse shooting
heroin you probably wouldn't be a fan of
that because you realize that even
though it's it's it's not going to
directly right this minute turn your kid
into a heroin addict or a pothead it
will influence them it will have the
effect of especially over time okay if
all cartoon characters started acting
this way they all became druggies it's
going to have the effect of influencing
desensitizing normalizing these things
and so you know that we all understand
that we all understand that have you
noticed that teens today don't smoke
cigarettes like they used to
now they smoke other things because as
I've said before I think I mean it's
kind of a losing battle it's just
they're gonna find something whether
it's your vaping
but they don't smoke cigarettes anymore
nearly as much as they used to have you
also noticed that characters on TV don't
smoke cigarettes like they used to I
mean if you go back and you watch TV
shows from the 50s and 60s everybody
smokes cigarettes every character
smoking all the time they don't anymore
nearly as much and kids don't smoke as
much is you think that's a coincidence
is that some kind of like there's an oh
well you know I'm who knows there's no
correlation no it's not a coincidence
and it's not as though any kid had ever
said oh I saw this particular character
smoking cigarettes so I'm going to run
out and get a cigarette no it's just
over time when your environment is
saturated with these kinds of images it
just has an effect of desensitizing
normalizing or even making whatever the
activity is seem cool okay and the
cigarette companies knew that that's why
for a long time they were paying these
TV shows to have the character smoke the
marketing industry in general has made
billions of dollars on the premise that
kids are influenced by media people are
influenced by the stuff they see on
screen kids or not you know if that
wasn't true the marketing industry
wouldn't exist instead rather it doesn't
just exist it runs our lives because
we're being marketed to so much I'm not
singling video games out I'm just saying
they aren't an exception they are in
influence - okay I'm doing the opposite
of signaling them out
it's the game or some of them many of
them who want to single out video games
as a form of media that somehow it has
no influence at all no detrimental
effect none it's ridiculous or at least
it's a fantastic claim see what we know
from our experience as as human beings
and from common sense that media affects
people it influences people it drives
people certain directions it normalizes
it these senses we know all of that no
but no person the right mind don't
denies that in as a general principle
now if you claim that
games are somehow an exception to that
rule even though it's a form of media
that kids are consuming hours a day and
not only consuming but actually
participating in they have it they have
a more direct participatory relationship
with the media that they're consuming as
video games if you're telling me that
that form of media somehow is an
exception completely from this that is a
fantastic claim and you need fantastic
extraordinary evidence to prove it
if you don't have it then we're going to
revert back to the rather safe and
logical assumption that yes it is
influencing kids to some extent to some
degree in some way now you know what you
will find in fact is that a lot of
defenders of video games will actually
claim that they can prove that that
video games don't influence kids and
don't have any link at all to violence
they mean you'll see this claim I'm sure
there are people making this claim right
now as we speak in the comment section
that are saying about it is it's been
debunked it's been proven there's no
link no link I've heard this so many
times I've heard his studies studies
have disproven the link I've even heard
people say after people say that every
study I've seen this claim many times
every study done has disproven the link
that's what I've heard
it's nonsense it is total nonsense if
you're making that claim you don't know
what you're talking about and you know
that you don't know your dough you're
talking about because you know you've
done no research because if you have
done any research you would know how
ridiculous that claim is it's not true
it just isn't I'm sorry it is true that
some studies some have failed to
establish a link between aggressive
behavior and video games that is not the
same thing as proving that there is no
link failing to establish a link is not
the same as disproving the link there's
a very clear distinction there there are
many things in life that are probably
linked that probably have some
relationship but you you you also
probably won't be able to prove the link
we just know it intuitively okay now
if you actually read some of these
studies and I've read them okay people
send me studies I've read all the
studies I actually read this I don't
just look at I read the studies read the
methodology read the results read the
conclusions what you're gonna find is
that these studies disproving a link
they're all they're all laughable
they're not just they're not just
illegitimate they're actually laughable
if you read the methodology there's one
of the one one study that was sent to me
and is touted as is maybe the most
conclusive and sort of far-reaching
study that's been done on it well and it
failed to establish a link didn't
disprove now the scientists who do these
studies they would never actually
themselves claim that they've disproven
anything because they're they're gonna
be a lot more careful in their wording
it's the media in their headlines I will
say link disproven even though that's
not what happened but in this one
particular study just as an example it
relied on self-reported data from gamers
themselves and their parents and what
you're gonna find as many of these
studies are relying on self-reported
data from one of those groups either the
gamers or the parents or both
this study was both okay so gamers
basically are asked whether they are
violent or have violent thoughts and
then and then and then the parents are
asked whether their kids are bouts
do you see the problem here you're
asking gamers to go against their own
interests to criticize themselves and
admit to a negative thing about
themselves and about their favorite
hobby shockingly they don't do it I mean
wow debunked whoa science folks amazing
can you believe that people who love a
certain hobby aren't necessarily eager
to admit that it has any influence
negative influence on them on them at
all amazing I just I can't believe it
well there you go matter is settled
folks or you're asking parents to admit
that their own kids are violent and that
their own parenting is flawed you're
asking parents to admit yeah I let my
kid play violent video games all the
time and you know honestly I'm seeing a
lot of aggression and
letting him do it anyway parents aren't
going to admit that parents are famously
infamously hesitant to to admit that
their kids have any flaws or that their
parenting is flawed ask any teacher
about this and they'll tell you ask any
teacher how eager parents are to fess up
or even to acknowledge to accept that
their kids have have any flaws so I mean
if this is the kind of study that you
think proves anything it's it's come on
come on I've also seen studies that
attempt to video vindicate video games
by drawing a one-to-one comparison
between the crime rate in a particular
area and the video games that have been
sold in that area
you know I saw one study that that shows
oh did you know that you know when a
certain video game goes on sale you know
not only is there less crime in the air
but there but or not only is there is
there not an increase in crime but
there's less crime well yeah because
everyone because all the kids are home
playing the video game for right now but
no one is claiming that it's a
one-to-one direct link no one is saying
that kids are playing the video games
and they're putting the video game down
and going out like a zombie and killing
each other because of what they just saw
nobody is saying that you're disproving
a claim that nobody on earth has made
another study had kids play video games
and then they came in and you looked at
a brain scan to analyze their empathy as
if empathy can be measured in a brain
scan like you could just look at someone
up well okay they have 80% apathy
empathise looking good folks I saw it in
the brain scan okay if any scientist
claims that they can conclusively
determine the link between your
neurological activity and your empathy
they're lying because they know they
can't it's what it's it's one of the
great mysteries and in science right now
is the nature of consciousness and as
again as if there's this direct link as
if as if your your empathy which you
can't measure but even if you could as
if your your empathy dwindles at direct
proportion to the amount of time you
spend playing violent video games no one
is saying that okay it's just I think
what we discover is that studies are
insufficient okay you you when you're
trying to analyze why people do
something especially why they commit an
act of egregious evil you're not gonna
be able to just do a study and say well
there it is solved it people are much
more complicated than that and and what
motivates people to act the way they act
ISM is a much more complex question okay
there are so many things that you do on
a daily basis so many choices that you
make which hopefully don't include
killing people but you make a million
choices in a day all of those choices
have been influenced by any number of
factors and we can use our intuition in
our common sense to kind of figure out
what some of those factors might be but
but you could never there's there's no
survey you could fill out that would
spell it out like a pie chart with exact
mathematical values it just does people
don't work that way which is why okay I
am NOT gonna try to prove my point by by
gesturing towards the studies that have
found a link between aggression and and
video games and those studies have been
done there are many studies that affect
the American Academy of Pediatrics which
i think is a you know a pretty good
authority when it comes to to these
sorts of issues the American Academy of
Pediatrics they according to them
according to their report there have
been 3,500 studies done about the
effects of violent media on kids
including video games and all but 18 of
them have found a link okay so this
claim that there are no studies is it's
just such a ridiculous lie it could not
be more 3500 that isn't none that's
3,500 and they found that all but 18
finally okay and and not all those
studies were focusing on video games
some of them were but the point is we
have a you know it appears based on all
these studies that violent media does
influence people and it influences kids
it that's that's what it appears but I'm
not even that's you know
I'm not gonna try to win by saying I
have more studies than you do even
though I do but that's that's not my
point it's just this is it's it's a
basic insight of human nature that
people are influenced by the images they
spend hours a day consuming here's the
real point okay
the real problem or potential problem
with video games
it isn't we're focusing on the violence
isn't really the violence I do think the
violence in video games like like
violence in movies and like violence on
TV and like violence and YouTube videos
and all it I do think that has a
desensitizing effect of course it does
obviously it does the human mind is
something that can be conditioned
certain ways this is this is this is a
again a fact of human nature and if
you're exposed to certain images a lot
even if the images are fake you become
desensitized to those images and
concepts this is one of the reasons why
kids are very much damaged
psychologically by their early exposure
to pornography yeah it's it's it's it's
not happening in the real world okay but
kids psychologically respond to exposure
to graphic pornography in a similar way
that they respond to sexual abuse what
you're gonna find psychologically in a
sexual abuse victim is something very
similar to what you find in a you know
say 10 year old kid has been exposed to
graphic pornography it's not the same
thing exactly but it has a similar
effect on you psychologically because
that's just how we are I mean we look at
images on a screen and we internalize
them that's the whole reason why we
enjoy watching movies in the first place
ok why do you even like watching a movie
you know that it's fake you know that
they're just pretending yet in the
moment when you sort of hand yourself
over to that to this you know you kind
of give yourself to this
to do the story that's being told and
you kind of get lost in it and you do in
a way sort of forget that it's fake
that's the only way you can enjoy it
right so it that shows again that images
have have a real effect on us but aside
from them the real issue potentially
with video games is that they are
isolating they breed isolation forget
about the vinyls I don't I don't care a
kid never plays any violent video games
forget about that the fact is when you
have kids rather than running around
outside rather than interacting on a
person-to-person basis rather than you
know rather than going out and like we
talked about taking risks and getting
their aggression out and climbing trees
and going on adventures rather than that
they're inside experiencing life in
virtual reality that is unhealthy that
is not a recipe for raising a
well-adjusted person so the real danger
of video games is that a kid obsessed
with them will be isolated alone inside
cut off that's the real danger and in
that case it doesn't even matter if
they're violent just like if you have a
kid who plays video games sparingly and
every once in a while plays a violent
video game I am sure probably has no
effect of basically no effect a
negligible effect or the other hand if
you have a kid who never plays violent
video games but he plays seven hours of
video games a day it never goes outside
he's gonna be destroyed by that the same
way he would be if he just watched seven
hours of TV a day or if he just stared
at his phone for seven hours a day which
a lot of people do a lot of us are being
destroyed by this mutated by it
psychologically emotionally spiritually
now there are people try to visit
vindicate video games by pointing out
that video games are very popular in
Asia yet mass shootings don't happen
they're true enough and if I or anyone
else was claiming that video games
directly caused violence in a one-to-one
relationship which I'm not but if I was
making that point then yeah the point
about Asia would blow my case out of the
water and you're right absolutely but
actually what I'm claiming is that video
games are a form of
number one and media number two
influences human behavior and also
number three video games breed isolation
and can be unhealthy and large doses
that's my claim okay and as it happens
in Asia people literally play video
games for days on end until they kill
over dead they play video games to death
they starve themselves while playing
video games in Asia and this is not just
one case this is a trend over there what
you have in Asia in a lot of these Asian
countries especially in the urban
centers you have a young generation that
has retreated from human life almost
completely and now they they live their
lives in virtual reality through video
games and computer games and somehow
what somehow you're saying that proves
that video games aren't harmful I've
been pointing to Asia as proof that
video games aren't harmful is like
pointing to Ireland or Russia as proof
that alcohol is no big deal that's the
worst place you could possibly look
that's it that's exactly people say what
about Asia yeah that's my point exactly
look at what's happening with the youth
over there look at what how many young
generations think they're not even
they've just collapsed into they've
rejected reality they just think live
every when you've got people going to
these internet cafes and playing video
games for 36 hours
that shows that videogames influence
people and that can influence in a
negative way
they breed isolation or they can and
being overexposed to them has negative
consequences now in order for a mass
shooting to be one of the potential
things that can be linked in some way
with video games in order for you need a
lot of other ingredients okay it's not
just gonna be video so a mass shooter
who spent hours a day playing violent
video games what I'm saying is I don't
think those facts are unrelated and I
think the claims are unrelated is absurd
on its face and not even worth taking
seriously and I have a hard time
believing that anyone actually believes
that it's completely unrelated but it's
Abby
not anywhere close to the only factor
and there were so many other things that
had to go into it but the video games
didn't help
certainly and and they probably did in
in some small way help to push towards
this result but there were a lot of
other things I mentioned fatherlessness
ok that's for a lot of these cases the
fatherlessness was a much bigger factor
but they all compound I talked yesterday
about the about the snowball effect and
it's just one thing after another after
another after another and eventually you
haven't Havelange
our video games part of the Avalanche
yes is internet part yes TV violence and
movies yes yes yes fatherlessness that's
a huge part lack of spiritual grounding
huge part problems in education another
big all of this stuff all I'm saying to
you is don't try to absolve videogames
completely and it you know agree with me
on all of these factors but then try to
pretend that videogames somehow are in
exception it just it's not only
laughably ridiculous but it we are
stopping ourselves from making small
improvements and the thing about video
games people always say well ok even if
all this is true what are we gonna do
about it well with something like video
games or internet usage with a lot of
these things I don't know what we can do
and I certainly am NOT looking to the
government to solve the problem but
something like video games if we could
acknowledge this is an issue then there
are things like well parents could do
more to regulate their own kids video
game consumption just something like
that there's a saloon there's there's
one small solution that will help in
some small way towards solving the
overall problem so you know but if we're
not allowed to talk about this that is
one small step that you are preventing
us from taking and I kind of resent that
all right that was longer there's a
longer video game thing than I thought
but we will we'll leave it there and
thanks everybody for watching
Godspeed if you prefer facts over
feelings if you aren't
by the brutal truth if you can still
laugh at the nuttiness filling our
national news cycle well tune on into
the ben shapiro show where you'll get a
whole lot of that and much more we'll
see you there